in this video i'm going to talk to you
about one of the questions that i get
most frequently and that i one of the
problems that i have to solve again most
commonly in some of the companies that
we take on in our portfolio
one of the goals of any business is to
maximize the amount of revenue per
customer you generate right and a lot of
times you want to have
what's what's called like an
accommodating buying curve and so what
that basically means is
at every rug right if someone is
wealthier you want them to buy more and
spend more money with you and if someone
has less money you want them to still
buy from you but potentially buy for
less right and so this gives way to a
lot of these crazy product and service
listings where people have you know 100
different services and products that
they offer because they want to have the
ability to serve everyone at the maximum
degree the thing is is that most times
that will create so much operational
complexity and create so many little
appendages right little sticky things
that are stuck onto the side and bolted
on and globbed and duct taped onto a
business that it becomes incredibly
distracting for all of the employees
because they're thinking about all these
different things and here's a funny one
is that most times if your employees
don't understand all the different types
of things you sell and the price points
you sell them at your customers for sure
don't one of the things that we will do
when we're looking at a company is we
will simplify the product offering and
instead
try and reach the maximum buying
threshold per prospect by changing the
payment terms now
in a perfect world if everyone had
absolute information and everyone was
unbelievably well trained and you had
great infrastructure and all that stuff
then yes the more products and services
you offer in theory you would make more
money but we don't live in that
theoretical world most of the time and
most small business owners are not that
good at operating right it's the number
one issue they have they're super
disorganized they feel like they're
spinning their reels all day their team
completely has no idea what which way
they're going they change things all the
time etc and so in an effort to combat
that we have used this process over and
over again and it has worked very well
so
it is as follows we sell two things and
i've done this in virtually every
business that i've ever owned
we sell two things
two products or two services and this is
once we're going from one to ten million
all right zero to one million you sell
one product and one service one avatar
all right that's it one channel one
product one avatar that's it right but
once you're going from one
to you know one to three ish million and
you're trying to go to ten
you introduce the second product line
and so here's how this works if you have
two things that you sell you'll have a
front-end thing and you'll have a
back-end thing we can still have a
massive accommodation in the buying
curve based on the payment terms that we
introduce so for example people will
look at their monthly expense
more than the total contract value
that's a huge money hack i'm giving you
right now this is a wealth hack this is
something that will build make you a
fortune in your life if you can properly
understand this
people do not look at the
length or the total contract they're
signing they will only pay attention to
what is it going to cost me every month
because no one is good with their money
all right so they only look at the cash
flow expense month over month over month
and they just think can i make it happen
yes cool i'll sign they don't think
about the total contract value for you
as a business owner the contract value
matters almost more than anything so
i'll give you a quick hack on this total
side note tangent for you life hack pro
tip if you want to extend the contract
value that you have i have a saying
which is the bigger the head the longer
the tail all right and so what that
means is the more you can get someone to
pay up front and relative to the upfront
cost of signing up or what they paid
down the lower their contractual
recurring payment is the stickier it
will be so i'll give you an example
if i had someone sign up for 99 a month
for whatever it doesn't matter that
price point might be medium sticky
depending on the value that i have now
imagine i had someone pay five thousand
dollars down and ninety nine dollars a
month after that how much more sticky
would it be significantly more sticky
now the beauty is if you have one of
these up front tight payments you can
also use that to liquidate your ad cost
cover your commissions for the
salesperson cover the upfront
fulfillment in onboarding which is going
to cost more for a new customer than an
existing customer and so you can build
all that in if you know that the thing
that you are selling has very high gross
margins then you can still have a lower
cost as long as you know that the person
is going to stay for a long time and so
based on how you structure the pricing
you can actually get some you can use
the pricing to actually get people to
stick longer pro tip complete that is it
moving back to the original thing that i
was talking about in one of our
portfolio companies we actually had this
as a really in-depth discussion that we
had to make a decision about all right
and so they had a different you know
mentor person whatever advice uh who
told them that they should have three
products and they should have a you know
low a medium and a high product and then
based on
you know what the salesman thought the
salesman would sell them the low medium
or high
in my experience it is not that
effective
and that is because the salesperson
can't decide
which of these things they are trying to
sell most of the time and so what we
have found is more effective is you give
the salesperson the one dream to sell
this thing is going to solve this
person's problem and we make it the most
valuable thing that we're trying to sell
because at the end of the day you do
want to solve the the customer's problem
right we do want to actually make sure
that we're providing value rather than
having a diet a medium and a grate right
simply having one thing that solves all
the problems and then based on the the
customer's budget
we can decrease how they pay all right
so hear me out
so let's say that uh we want to do a uh
this is a six month implementation of
whatever kind of solution you sell if
you have a six month duration you can
have the person a pay the entire thing
up front so that would be for somebody
who has
the highest budget version two would be
a split pay version three might be three
payments right with at twenty percent
higher and then finally you might have a
have a have a you know a six pay or
whatever over that period of time so one
two three six now here's the cool thing
the more payment options you provide the
higher your conversions are that's
proven all right so the more options you
give someone to pay the more people will
buy
period now you might not make more cash
flow because if you give your sales guy
more options then they might use though
they'll end up defaulting to the lower
ones right but if you have one thing to
sell then they only have one thing to
convince the person of because a
confused mind doesn't buy if you have
too many options the salesman won't know
what to sell and the prospect won't know
what to buy and so i prefer when i'm
coming into our portfolio company i'm
thinking what is this true problem that
we are solving with this business for
what avatar
and we make that the main thing and we
communicate it clearly in the scripting
and the sales person has clarity on what
they are selling and they're always
solving the same thing and so the
question becomes no longer which of
these things are you going to buy but
once you are buying how would you like
to pay and so then the discussion is
around what payment plan is best for
them rather than what product is best
for them and so by doing that you can
get people to go between different
payment terms that is not going to
change whether they're going to buy but
if they're unsure about which product is
going to best suit their needs and the
salesman doesn't know because at the end
of the day he's just trying to sell the
most expensive thing then you'll have
way more confused people who leave on
soul so this is a single tactic that you
can use to execute within your business
which is why i'm a big fan of making
offers people cannot say no to is that
you can focus all of your sales and all
of your persuasion attempts on selling
the one thing which is getting them to
say yes once they say yes we can we can
reach the we can accommodate their
wealth and their budget based on the
payment terms that we provide and if we
have done or we've structured our offer
properly the offer in and of itself
should already be very high gross
margins which means whether or not the
person pays a thousand dollars a month
or a hundred dollars a month it's still
almost all margin for us because of how
we structure the thing that we are
selling
and so we are able to capture higher
ltvs by getting the people who have more
money to prepay the thing up front that
is how we do it and with those people
you'll be able to ascend into the second
thing
faster because they've already prepaid
that thing and then you can solve the
next natural problem in another sales
conversation rather than trying to pick
all of the things in one conversation
which makes it incredibly difficult to
do this is just for everyone again a
broad brush stroke of statements for
most entrepreneurs who are not very good
at operating their businesses uh her
operations is not their strong suit and
are below three million dollars a year
all right so anyways moseynation there's
a lot of people who are broke i don't
want to be one of them which is why i
make these videos keep being awesome i
love you and i'll see you guys next bit
bye